you know the networks and the media have
sort of framed these games around you
and your Rising Star you meanwhile have
constantly talked about winning and the
team how do you balance those values
with the fact this is a stard driven
league and people are excited to learn
more about you yeah that's a great
question I think that that's what like
you said it's a star driven League um in
a world that's so like me me me um I
just want the focus to be on you know
our group and our team and what we do um
you know I think that there's a it's
kind of tiring I think the the inseason
tournament's been really good because
it's forc and us having success has been
good because I think it I feel like it's
forced the media to talk about
basketball and talk about what's in
front of you and not have to talk about
legacies and all the the BS that come
with it and talk about actually talk
about basketball so um you know I think
that's what's been good about us
succeeding and of course there's going
to be the you know people have said MVP
or all NBA Allstar whatever like that
happens but at the end of day I just
want to play basketball and I want to
succeed as a team and I know that team
success individual success comes with
that so um I think that that's been
something that I really enjoyed about
our run right now is that it's forced
the media to talk about what's in front
of them which is basketball and uh I
think as a person who loves the sport I
think everybody can appreciate that
great